[Music]
it's surprisingly common for a video
game to be cancelled during its
development
maybe the mechanics just aren't that fun
or the art style is little dated or the
narrative is underwhelming or worse
still someone on high decides the
developers are better used on other
projects usually the decision to cancel
a game are within reason but sometimes
it's a crying shame and a potential
masterpiece is left gathering dust with
that in mind here are seven canceled
video games that would have been epic
that's deep breath it'll be the last
fresh air you'll get for a while
star wars games are a staple of most
people's childhood
that was until eh up the license and
forced microtransactions upon us and
made us all pay to win one Star Wars
title we will never play his Star Wars
1313 it was going to be set on the
planet city of Coruscant on level 13 13
to be more precise the game was based
around an unnamed bounty hunter making
it through the criminal underworld as
the project gained attention George
Lucas himself changed the unnamed bounty
hunter into the greatest bounty hunter
of all time
Boba Fett this all started at e3 back in
2012 the story was going to be less
about good versus evil and more about
the ambiguous grey areas between the
light and the dark so in essence this
was made for a more mature audience 1313
would have been very much like uncharted
with a third-person cover based shooter
system including lightning fast action
scenes and cinematic cutscenes to rival
the film's
when Disney acquired LucasArts
lucasfilm's and every little bit of the
Star Wars franchise they abandoned the
1313 license forever damming it to
canceled videogame hell just imagine a
Star Wars game about the criminal
underbelly of Khorasan could have been
absolutely phenomenal but all well back
to loot crate's I suppose thank you eBay
back in 2006 a ps3 demo for a game
titled eight days was revealed at e3
produced by London studio the game was
set to take place over eight days across
eight different states of the u.s. at
the time they were looking to break
boundaries and create the largest map in
gaming history filled with cinematic
heroism like hanging from a bank vault
from a helicopter or playing hot potato
with a gun and pointlessly switching
cover both pretty cool the brilliance of
this game was that it was real time so
if it was nighttime when you were
playing in real life it was nighttime in
the game two-a-days also planned to have
two protagonists going down the usual
route of one good one that each
character would then stumble across the
other one multiple times during the
campaign honestly how ethic does that
sound I'd love to play that sadly eight
days vanished and wasn't heard from
again it looked like the magnitude of
the project was its downfall and the
lack of online play halted things
further but there is a shining light at
the end of this tunnel London studio
have said this project is on hold rather
than being answered completely so maybe
just maybe one day we will play eight
days
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking
[Music]
even though this is a playstation
channel there are some canceled games on
other consoles that had the potential to
be brilliant
[Music]
during Microsoft's e3 2014 press
conference an exclusive action RPG was
announced scalebound this was a Western
attempt at the genre which to this point
had been perfected by Japanese Studios
playing as drew with a pet dragon
progressing through the world of
Draconis one of the gimmicks of the game
which I absolutely loved was the
headphones that Dru wore during extended
fight scenes he would actively pump up
the music giving us an awesome
soundtrack to fight - the game had
ridiculously sized enemies and the
ability to play with friends online it
was shaping up to give Xbox players and
exclusive to be really proud of but the
game then missed its 2016 release window
and on January the 9th 2017 the
scalebound was officially cancelled
Microsoft brushed over the cancellation
stating after careful deliberation
Microsoft Studios has come to a decision
to end the production of scalebound yeah
that's it no explanation really it's
gone it's just gone what a shame
how freaking brilliant is the Batman
Arkham series well things could have
been a little different if an earlier
game was released back in 1989 the comic
book or graphic novel if you prefer
Gotham by Gaslight was released fast
forward to 2010 and Daewoong Studios
began looking into creating a video game
around it the story took Batman back in
time and pitted the greatest detective
of all time against the most infamous
serial killer of all time Jack the
Ripper somehow Jack has come to Gotham
and in 1889 Batman must use gadgets and
weapons that were from that time period
to capture the Ripper so this was filled
with steampunk vibes similar to those
seen in the order 1886 the cool mechanic
in this title would have been from the
police force believing you were Jack the
Ripper meaning you were both hunter and
afraid
Bruce Wayne you're under arrest you
can't imagine I'm actually the Ripper
sadly apart from these shots of Batman's
cape looking damn impressive the project
went under THQ were in the process of
acquiring the Batman license and then
suddenly went out of business and Batman
Gotham by Gaslight vanished from
existence if the story of Gotham by
Gaslight interests you then you'll be
happy to know that DC have recently
completed work on an animated version of
the story but it's highly unlikely we'll
ever get to play a steampunk Batman Oh
we are the true patriots
a new balance of power the growth of
Rainbow six siege has been astounding
its player base continues to grow here
upon Mira well in 2010 Ubisoft had a
different vision for the next Rainbow
six game
Rainbow six Patriots Patriots had your
team going up against a homegrown threat
in the shape of the true patriots across
new york the militia group you were
facing were acting for the people who
were wronged by the wall street
corruption and in the single-player
portion of the game you'd feel the boots
of different operatives nothing
groundbreaking I know but a little
different from many first-person
shooters out there at the time only
three months
after the game was first revealed the
lead designer the animation director and
the narrative director were all removed
from the project leaving Patriots in
limbo Ubisoft realigned their
expectations and began work on Rainbow
six siege which arguably is a better
direction for the series so maybe is
true every cloud does have a silver
lining sorry over here now
at the ps1 classic legacy of kain was an
absolute must play back in the 1990's
and Soul Reaver built upon that
extremely well way but by the time
defiance was released the franchise had
taken a bit of a nosedive ease in secret
all the way back in 2009 climax studios
began working on legacy of kain dead son
an open-world adventure merging
Nintendo's Legend of Zelda mechanics
with soul Reavers lore and narrative it
sounded bloody brilliant but when we
finally had the chance to see the
footage it was already too late the
project had been camped to this day
there is a nondisclosure agreement in
place so details are a little hard to
find but Simon Gardner the CEO of climax
went on record to say the game didn't
see the light of day due to changes in
video game business models but he also
says that he remains on good terms with
the publisher Square Enix since 2015
everything has been completely silent on
the Kane series but maybe it's time to
revisit that Universal and more time
potentially the greatest game that will
never see the light of day is silent
hill's following on from the ultra
successful Silent Hill series the game
was set to take horror video games into
a new echelon of fear and wonderment
switching from the typical third-person
perspective to actually see in the
horror from the hero's point of view the
project had videogame heavyweight hideo
kojima on board and hollywood director
Guillermo del Toro here to making the
9th Silent Hill title one of the biggest
height trains in history when
PlayStation users finally got their
hands on the silent hill's demo named PT
4 playable teaser everyone knew this
game was going to sell millions and
instantly become the pinnacle of horror
the demo itself included no weapons and
a repeating corridor which slowly
unraveled a tale of murder with talking
blood filled bags foetus like baby
things in sinks unbeli sir
those who completed the demo found out
who the main character was it's bloody
Darrell from The Walking Dead
good old Norman Reedus suddenly the hit
the fan and the whole project fell to
pieces
due to the conflicts between Hideo
Kojima and the publisher Konami silent
Hills was cancelled Kojima was released
and the demo was removed and all
advertising vanished completely kijima
went on to work with Sony and is
currently working on death stranding
which coincidentally stars Norman Reedus
again oh and look who's here - its
Guillermo del Toro we will have to wait
and see if this really is a successor to
silent Hills but one thing is for
certain it looks like a complete mind so
there we have it my picks for seven
cancelled video games that would have
been epic and probably made more money
than is humanly possible we could try
and see this as a blessing maybe if they
were released they'd be filled with
pay2win loot boxes anyway are there any
canceled video games you wish you could
have played please let me know your
musings in the comments below I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade and I'm going
back to play the PT demo just one more
time
[Music]